all right Poulos gamer so today we're
gonna be playing this new game called
Wilson's heart on the oculus rift
Wilson's heart oculus rift this is
virtual reality yes my theory and I've
said this before is that all VR is going
to take us one place virtual reality sex
that's the point of VR and so I assume
I'll be having sex today mate maybe is
there sexist part of the game
I mean not read Ivan please and they're
wasting their time the whole point of
virtual reality is to get it it's a
different world Irby inanimate objects
yes then I'll figure something out yeah
so you're Robert Wilson a 63 year old
man what where am I you what do you mean
you're in a hospital you went into exist
me am I am I in my body right now
yeah you're in your but look you look
down in your hands ah I look I look
gross mine I'm old okay I have a couple
of questions how do I make it this all
in color well it's in black and white
the game is an homage to a monster
movies of like the 30s and 40s wait a
minute I thought the whole point of
virtual reality was to enhance reality
and you're saying I've entered a world
where I'm colorblind and I'm an old man
yeah
Wow that's fantastic if you want to
experience what it's like to be in your
late 60's and oiled and chained to a
wall with glaucoma until this magical
world I should be having sex
oh so you can pick that up you can also
throw it if you want okay this lamp
tonight oh another one comes down that's
frustrating is that my voice yeah that's
yeah you're actually a Peter Weller you
know Robocop yeah oh he doesn't sound
good
there's water all over the floor you
know the if you look up the ceiling yeah
okay so I'm giving this hospital a very
bad yelp with you okay let's grab this
clipboard well there sure are using VR
to its highest potential
I'm in the bathroom my god look at my
face are they coming out you enter a
world we are uncoordinated experience
what it's like to be prosy sorry but
this is so far the only fun I've had in
this game you know this is the only
thing I want to do a gentle pinch
oh right you're like solving mystery if
they want me to solve a mystery they
shouldn't leave virtual quick clap falls
around ooh schemer yeah pretty sweet
fine there so much scribble book God
Sigmund Freud why is his crotch area
temple it's like they want me to fiddle
with that this game is trying to make me
messing around with a dead guys crotch
that's creepy are you Sigmund Freud who
did you secretly want me to play with
your crotch area okay all right what
were you scared at all what scared you
the most I'm scared that you know
without Obamacare now that's what
hospital
are you want more action yes yes okay no
I've loved walking around in the damp
love them on your arm then rub them on
your and kind of let go there yep that's
how you put gloves on oh look there's
something in here oh I see
that I could have sex with okay I
grabbed it from either side like a
toaster I think I'm just making a bed
gap there go down yeah go there you
gotta go back and get it again no don't
make any man damn you you creature from
hell all right be patient monster
monsters patiently been waiting for me
[Music]
[Applause]
Jerry Lewis deflating at the end
okay so Wilson's heart on the oculus
rift what do you think the graphics are
very impressive it's a very well
realized imaginative world just not a
world I want to live in because
basically I put on the VR helmet and
entered my life in 20 years I'll be old
I'll be stumbling around I'll be
uncoordinated I'll probably see things
in black and white by that point women
won't make eye contact with me and I'll
be ignored and I'll have Peter dwellers
voice in my head so if you want to know
what it's like to be confused infirm
weak and wandering around not knowing
what's happening play this game
[Applause]
you